all right
armanda yes armando where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
i grew up in lincoln heights my
grandparents
um lived up in
northeast area of l.a yes
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents yes i had both of my
parents
um it was a pretty good
um family i had a normal family
but my father was an alcoholic
and he was into his addiction
my grandparents practically raised me
off and on
he would beat my mom and me up
i had a brother but he never touched my
brother he wouldn't
beat him up just me and my mom because
he was a very bad
uh alcoholic and we're native americans
so you know
indians can't drink and
through all that i started learning how
to
sell drugs be around gangs be around
gang members and i started learning how
to
dip sherms and
pcp how to make angel dust
through watching my dad and
when my grandfather passed away when i
was 12 years old
that's when everything went downhill for
me
i got into my addiction i was smoking
sherm
and i learned how to do the angel dust
so i started making angel dust
and then from the angel dust i started
doing heroin and
from that i had a choice by then i
already had kids
of my own when i was 17. and i had to
make a choice either it was going to be
my family or it was going to be the
drugs well i learned
that i couldn't have two things i
couldn't have
a family and do my drugs so
i had to make a choice and the choice
that i chose was my drugs
i couldn't raise my family and still try
to
contain a habit it wasn't a conscious
choice it was just the addiction does
that to you
yes and in order for me to take care of
my habit i couldn't raise my kids
so my husband and family raised my
children
the penitentiary raised me and foster
care raised some of them
two of them two of them were raised by
my in-laws
my husband at the time didn't know that
i was a heroin addict i hid it from him
for a long time
so he was basically taking care of my
habit and didn't even know it
until i left when i came down here on
skid row i don't even know what brought
me down here but when i came down here
i started learning how to
be able to survive down here being a
female people take advantage of you
so i couldn't let that happen
i'm a very strong-willed person female
and i couldn't allow men
to try to use me like that although i've
been raped
i've been kidnapped at gunpoint
i've been held hostage
um tortured
you know it's not a fun life and there's
nothing glamorous about it
you know um
people think like
i don't know if you're a gang member if
you have tattoos
you know like some people glorify all
that stuff when you've been there and
done that but there's nothing exciting
about this life
nothing um what it does is it causes
more trauma added on top of trauma
then you have uh jails and prisons and
then you have
detox centers and programs and then
you're in and out of those
and you know it becomes a revolving door
and the whole time i'm in my addiction
and then when i get sober i
cry because then i want my family back
you know i cry because i can't see my
kids i cry because i want my husband
back i cry because
i want that consistency of normalness
i want something in my life to be
normal because at this point there's
nothing
normal in my life um
and then sometimes
you know when you're not ready
it creeps back up the addiction creeps
back up
and you end up going back into that
whole that cycle all over again
you know but that's why then you would
have to stay connected to people that
are
in a n a if that's what you choose or
people that are sober or
whatever it is that you find that's
normal stick with that
and that helps you me on the other
choice i used
i don't know i used all that but i just
wasn't ready to get clean
and i wasn't ready to stop using i
learned how to hustle down here
and i used my ability that i used and my
brains to get what i needed to get
and i hustled i sold for drug dealers i
ran
for them i i would jump in and out of
cars
i would do whatever it took to get what
i had to get
jumping prostituting
and um i would have to sell my body i
even dated a police officer
he would come to the back streets of
town every night at nine o'clock
and i would meet him and i jump down in
the back and then we take off and then
we go
up on the parking lot and it was like
consistent every time he came i already
knew the routine
and he wouldn't pick anybody up but me
and i guess um i don't know when
when i got incarcerated i don't know
what happened to him
you know so you would be surprised the
people that
you meet down here you know you you meet
doctors you meet artists
um you meet people that were in bands
that used to have a life and
somehow you know they got strung out on
pills
and then the doctor takes it away from
them so then they end up down here
on dope you know you would think like
god i come from this
normal family and these people like had
it all
like if they had what i would say if i
had what they had i wouldn't
there's no way but you know what
everybody has
something that's sad in their life that
causes them
to drink to escape yes
i learned that you know there's
just different diseases whether it be
gambling
sex smoking you know i mean
you think that drugs are just an
addiction and it's not
basically everything is an addiction you
know
just some people know how to function
better than others
some people know how to hide it better
than others
i came you know i remember one time my
dad telling me boy you sure know how to
lie good
you know that's one thing you did was
picking up lying you you do that wow
so i guess i used that to my ability
you know i learned how to lie really
good
it's a skill yeah pretty much
you know so
i mean i i just learned everything that
i had to do
so i can get what i had to get sugar
daddies
you know you're gonna tell them anything
just so they can
help you with money drugs or take you
where you got to go
you know so
that's what i did yeah you know and when
you sold drugs
you saw all kinds of customers all kinds
of people not oh
yeah yes i had
guys coming from the valley girls
they're from costa mesa i mean these
people had
money and they would come and they would
buy grams and ounces
and i'm like what are you guys coming
all the way down here for and they're
like well you know
everybody always it's a chain
you tell so on and so on and so on and
so on you know it just goes and then you
finally find out about downtown now lay
skid row
and then everybody ends up down here
eventually
you know because this is where your
disease brings you
you know and they say that even if
you're in disease that you're
not clean i mean you're clean you can go
back to where your disease was
and you can stay clean but that can
happen for me
when you come back to a place where your
disease was it sucks you back up and it
takes you right back to your disease
because
you're so familiar with it that's all
you know
is that and you fall right back into the
cycle
i got cleaned off my heroin five years
and
i ended up coming back and started
smoking crack again
is that what you're using today yes i've
been clean off a crack for 50
i mean for heroin for 15 years
and i've been on methadone that's how i
got off of that
but then i started smoking crack and now
i can't get off of that that's hard for
me to get off
how do you compare heroin and crack well
heroin
is a body it's a physical
thing you know you get sick physically
if you don't have it right and
crack is just a mental thing you just
tell yourself you have to have it like
you just want to keep trying to chase
that first hit
that first numbness and you never get it
so you keep chasing it so the more money
you spend on it
because you want to feel that way that
you did that very first time
but it doesn't happen after the first
one it never happens again after
but you still need it no you don't need
it so i mean why don't you just quit the
crack
because my body just tells me why not
just go and get it
just go and do another one let's just go
get another one because i like to stay
high
i don't like to deal with my trauma i
don't like it so there's still some uh
numbing oh a lot with crack there's
still a lot and i numb it with a
with crack that's what numbs might
my pain my my discomfort
it numbs my um
if if i'm upset um my depression
it numbs all that and it makes me be
able to
to kind of function yeah you seem you
know a lot of crack acts that i've
interviewed
seem pretty functional like they could
get jobs it seems like they could
get their lives together and still use
am i am i wrong
um on crack
they never do i mean at least the ones
i've met are all on the street but
but it seems like some could yeah i mean
you can
if you can maintain it i guess they just
lose the discipline or the will to just
show for work and do all that
right when you can show up for work and
get a paycheck coming every week and
still get high on the weekends
that's functioning addicts that's what
i'm saying yeah down here there's no
but there's no functioning anything yeah
no but crack is a drug where you can
kind of get away with that
you can but heroin not so much no heroin
you can't there's just no way that you
can do it because heroin affects the
body and the mind so much
there's just no way you physically get
sick
get ill and crack you to sleep you get
hungry and you sleep
you sleep or you stay up well when
you're on crack you stay up but
eventually you'll be able to sleep
no but uh cocaine and crack are drugs
where it almost seems like you might be
able to pull it off
and on meth if you stay up
then eventually you're gonna go sleep
for
four days or five days and eat because
you're in a cocaine coma
and on heroin you're just you know
you can't sleep when you're on heroin
you stay up for 30 days
at a time because you can't sleep
you're physically your bones you just
want to curl
up in a ball and die that's how bad it
gets
and nobody told me that you get sick
the guy that got me hooked on it was
helping me paint my house my grandmother
had left
to texas to live with my aunt and i took
over my grandmother's apartment
it was a two bedroom uh i paid 310 back
then
in the 80s and uh the guy that was
helping me was uh
upstairs was a neighbor and i was buying
dope every day for him to help me paint
my house and i was
chipping that's what you call chipping
doing it once in a while
and he would fix me and then he never
told me what it was going to do to me i
was going to get hooked i was going to
get sick this is what was going to
happen he never said nothing
of course he didn't want me to stop i
was supporting his habit
you know i was getting him well
and i didn't even know that until i
started getting sick at first i thought
it was like
a flu you know my nose is running
i'm getting chills i'm getting hot
flashes and i'm thinking what's wrong
with me am i coming down with the cold
then i find out it's because i'm hooked
on heroin
you know and i was like oh my god this
guy didn't even tell me how
stupid you know
and eventually he died of aids
you know his disease got him
sick and i didn't find out that he had
aids
until a while later but i never used
behind him
i i always have my own syringe i never
used behind them
thank god you know because
i would take tests all the time and i
didn't have it thank god
but when you come down here and you're
sick
you don't care what cooker you use
you don't care who syringe you use you
don't care what kind of water it is
you just want to fix so you'll pick up
anything
a used syringe somebody that's got one
that you don't care if they have hipsie
or if they have aids
you you don't care and that's where the
unprotected sex comes into play too
right
right why would anyone ever do that
you're a disease because you're so
desperate and
that's what i did and i ended up getting
hepatitis c
by using somebody else's cooker and
somebody else's syringe
thank god that that's all i had through
the years
i had found out and i was like oh my god
this is what's gonna kill me so now i
know what's gonna i'm gonna die of
then they came out with the cure for the
hep c
you take a pill for three months and you
you um
fix it and that's what i did so minds is
no longer active
but you
you get when you get clean you have to
respect the drug that you choose
to do because if you don't you'll go
back to it
so you need to respect it enough not to
use it anymore not to pick it up
because you're not just hurting your
family you're hurting yourself too
you know and when you go out there you
take your family with you but we don't
think about that
and i took mine out with me every time i
went out my mom always used to tell me
i'm waiting for that phone call
and now i know what she's going through
because i'm waiting for the same thing
for my son
because he's in his addiction is that
what worries you the most
yeah i worry about him a lot you'll lose
your son
yeah that's what i worry about because
like me what is his bottom jails
and institutions were mine and my oldest
son told me i'll take your grandkids
away from you and you'll never see them
again if you go back to using
so i stopped using because i didn't want
my grandkids to be taken out of my life
and you know now i know
what it feels like to have a child on
drugs
because he's in his addiction and now
he's using heroin too
so he's doing meth and heroin and he's
schizophrenic
so you know he's all over the place but
he panhandles he doesn't rob
he doesn't do anything like that he
panhandles but still
anybody could kill him being out there
and he lives in iraq
you know that's where we used to live
so that's where he stays
and he used to be so germaphobic now i
can't even get him to take a shower
can't even get him to take a shower and
um
his arms they say are really really bad
like they're just abscesses and
everything
and i want to go and see them and i want
to go out there and
tell them look you know you're
36 years old let's get off the street
let's get you to a program but i have to
do it when he's ready
you know i can't force him
because i learned with all the people
that wanted to help me i didn't want
their help i had to do it when i was
ready
you know they're ready for you but you
you got to be ready yourself and you
really have to not want it
to stay clean you know so
you it sounds like you're you feel a
sense of accomplishment from quitting
heroin
yeah but but using crack no
i still feel that self
loathing you know that i'm still a piece
of [ __ ] kind of stuff
because i'm still using crack
so i still feel like i'm that still that
piece of [ __ ]
you know like i i'm never gonna
accomplish anything i can't do nothing
right
i didn't raise my kids so you're a bad
mother
you're not even a mother you know
that kind of stuff i still have and i
i hold on to that and i should let that
go if i let a lot of things go
maybe maybe it would stop me from using
but because i hold on to a lot of it it
keeps me in my addiction yeah the shame
and guilt
keeps keeps the cycle going right right
and that's so true
the more you use the bet the worse you
feel the worse you feel the more you use
yup and it's true you know
just like they say one's a thousand and
every you know one's too many and a
thousand is never enough
you know and that's really honestly true
you know
then i got my husband smoking crack and
once you got him smoking
crack forget it he spends his whole
check in one day he can't stop
he just goes on it's all over
and i could be tired of smoking i'd be
like [ __ ] i'm done now
let's go to sleep and he's still wanting
me to go out and make runs
you know that's just how he gets so i
could never put it in his face because i
know how
what's gonna happen then he starts
feeling bad the next day then it's
the woe is me then i get blamed for it
because if i never put it in his face he
would have never did it you know so then
there it goes again that i'm the one
you know so nobody ever wants to
admit to their wrongs take
responsibility yeah
you know i'll throw it on her she's the
one that got me going she's the one that
started it she brought it up
so it's her fault
so i just suck it up and just say okay
well [ __ ] it they already blame me
anyway
so it's me it's all me
so i already know anything that i do
it's just gonna get thrown in my face or
you know they're
still gonna say something you know and
then my brother
was the one that i was the black sheep
in my family my cousin was the black
sheep in his family
and then my dad was the black sheep of
all of us and my brother was supposed to
be
the good son he's the one that was
supposed to have the family and raise
his kids and raise his grandson he has
one grandson he just had
for the first time he's in his 40s and
you know he's supposed to be the good
one come to find out just a couple of
months ago i find out that my brother
has molested three of his
baseball um
guys he's an umpire and he molested
three of the boys on his team
and i'm like and he's supposed to be the
good sheep
and he's a molester but i'm the black
sheep
wow where is that uh
hello so now he's busted he's
incarcerated and he's fighting
he's fighting for his life right now so
how dare you
tell me when you need to clean your own
backyard before you try to clean mine
you know because look what you've done
yeah you know you're going to have to
stay pc'ed in your family for i mean
in jail for the rest of your life your
family don't even want nothing to do
with you anymore
you know even your mother says that she
believes that you did it
you know and he had my mother shut me
out all her life
all my life basically you know but i was
the black sheep
go figure that so
you know me and my husband we laugh
about it now but
it's pretty sad yeah your whole family
generation after generation right now
where does it end where does it stop my
dad committed suicide
you know he finally had committed
suicide he just couldn't take it anymore
my mom had left him i had abandoned him
my brother didn't want anything to do
with him you know the kids
my gran his our kids didn't know him he
basically didn't have a life anymore so
he
he just ended up getting out of prison
doing i think like 19 and then he ended
up just committing suicide
i didn't cry i couldn't
there was so much trauma there i
couldn't cry for him
i didn't feel sorry i just thought okay
well he finally
did it it was the chicken [ __ ] way to do
it but he finally did it
to end his suffering you know
and i try to talk to him so many times
to find out why he did what he did to us
but he always refused to talk to me
well you say did what he did to you what
did he do beat me
he threw my animals my bird i had two
birds in a cage he threw it in the
street
for the cars to run him over he killed
my fish
you know he would just do these weird
[ __ ] and i'm like why do you do these
things to my animals and he's like to
hurt you because i know that's what's
going to hurt you
and i'm like but they're innocent they
didn't do anything to you
you know why would you torture my
animals
you know so all the mental physical
and emotional abuse that he did to me
and my mother
i tried to talk to him about and he
never wanted to answer
he never had an answer for any of it he
just didn't want to talk about it
i need closure from that stuff
to let it go and i just couldn't get any
he he basically robbed me from my whole
house
he sold my couches he sold my crib
he saw my tv he sold everything in my
house
down to my plant to the connection
i went over to the connections house and
i heard these chimes
and i go god that sounds so familiar how
they make
sounds my mother my grandmother had gave
me these chimes of these little owls and
i know the sound of them
and when i told frankie that was his
name what is making that sound and
he says it's a little chime that i have
under my plant and i said where and it
was in his house and i seen it i go
where did you get that plant he goes oh
your dad sold it to me for ten dollars
of
cocaine for ten dollar paper
i go that was my plan he even stole my
plant
and sold it to the connection i couldn't
believe it and i had i was already clean
and i was just like god this
this man just not didn't do anything he
did everything
all right armando thank you sir thank
you thank you for sharing your
interesting story
thank you and good luck with the rest of
your life thank you thank you very much
you're a good storyteller oh my god that
is so sad my dad is
like a piece of work
you